[Music]
our next speaker is professor rajiv
khanna
from qimi berghofer medical research
institute australia
professor khanna has been awarded order
of australia
in 2017 and has been elected as a fellow
of australian academy of health and
medical sciences
topic of professor khanna's talk is
combining
immunodiagnostics and immunotherapy for
clinical management of
infectious complications in transplant
patients
over to you professor khanna
good morning everybody today i'm going
to speak on the topic
how we can combine immunodiagnostic and
immunotherapy for clinical management of
infectious complications
in transplant patients here are my
disclosures in particular i want to
highlight links with
atara biotherapeutics this company we
have been working with for
almost now four years four to five years
on development of the t cell therapies
for cmv and abv
infectious complications remains a
significant challenge
and there are three different stages
when these
infections cause significant mobility
and mortality in transplant patients
in early phase we often see bacterial
infections
and then we see the middle period the
late period which is going up to six
months or beyond
you start seeing reactivation of these
viral infections these are persistent
latent viral infection particularly i
want to highlight the
infections like cytomegalovirus
epstein-barr virus or varicella
zostovirus
viruses often arise from the recipient
himself either the latent infection
getting reactivation
or you could get actually infection
being transmitted through the
transplanted organ or stem cells
bringing these infections
it is very critical to identify what the
source of these infections
are what are the strategies used
for the treatment of these or con
prevention of these viral reactivations
every clinical center seems to have a
different strategy and
the the traditional way is to treat all
patients that is
to give them antiviral prophylaxis from
day one
and continue up to maybe up to three to
six months or even longer than
six months up to nine months in the
heartland transplantation
there are other options available as
well for example the royal brisbane
hospital in brisbane
uses a preemptive strategy what do you
mean by preemptive is that the patient
is continuously monitored for
any viral reactivation particularly in
this case cmb or abv
and if there isn't any evidence of
certain level of viral reactivation
the patient is only given treatment if
there is a detectable virus
the other strategy is to use a
combination of both
preemptive and prophylactic therapy and
whereas the patient could initially be
treated using preemptive strategy
or given early prophylaxis and then
preemptive strategies so you give him a
set period of reflexes
and then using the whether there is any
reactivation of the virus
you give the pre-emptive therapy however
the long-term use of these via
these anti-viral drugs do cause
significant problems and in particularly
the drug resistance remains a
significant challenge
the other problems are the toxicity and
the cost of these these drugs
and it's been reported in the literature
that the long-term use of these viruses
and drugs
causes late viral diseases or rear viral
reactivation
and approximately 20 percent of these
patients should show
viral reactivation or the late viral
reactivation and the mortality and the
mobility in these patients is extremely
high
and could be up to 40 to 50 percent
there has been number of attempts made
to either predict or identify patients
who are at the high risk of developing
these viral reinfection
um we have been sort of been interested
in this area for many years and have
tried to develop an immunological sort
of a strategy of monitoring
to to to to monitor the infectious
complication in this
in the transplantation in collaboration
with
an australian company celestis inc which
is now owned by coijan we actually have
developed
a simple whole blood test which is now
marketed in europe and
and in australia and also in the u.s um
which is definitely as quantiferon cmb
this quantifying cmv kit
includes three tubes uh one tube is nil
that is
anything and the other tube has another
second tube has the
the cmb peptides and third tube has
mitogen
and the myogen gives you global t cell
stimulation where the cmb
antigen gives the activation of the t
cells so these cells
the blood is drawn into these vacutainer
tubes and
up to one million each tube and then you
incubate this tube for overnight at 37
degrees
and then you measure interference gamma
in the plasma and this actually a
graphic representation shows you how to
predict or how to analyze the
quantiferon read
results if the patient shows
in different gamma levels after
stimulation with cmv peptides above 0.2
international units
it's considered to be a safe level that
there is a robust
cmb specific t cell response and we
don't need to worry about this
if the patient choose below 0.2
international units
it's considered to be high risk the
patient is likely to have complications
associated with cmb and here is an
example how we have used this
quantifying kit to monitor the stem cell
transplant patient
here you're seeing two different um
patients
shown in the highest group and two
patients in the lowest group as a
representative
the the darker lines are shown here
are the actually the the cmb quantifier
on response the reactivity
in the test tube the dotted lines at the
viral load
and on the top you see these gray bars
are actually the antiviral drugs
as you can see this patient number on
the both high risk patients
continue to have much lower quantiferon
and seem to be losing the immunity
and the viral reactivation starts and
becomes persistent in this patient
whereas those patients at the low risk
actually who
show high level of quantifying response
show very little viral reactivation and
maintain a stable immunity
uh against the virus
we've also shown that in the same study
where when you actually have a
negative quantifier on response by day
60 which by two months approximately
you have a very high probability of cmv
reactivation up to eighty percent
whereas if your cmv posits quantify on
positive
bias by two months you have a much lower
chance of cmb reactivation so
clearly showing the acquisition of a
positive quantity front cmv test
is coincident with protection from cmb
reactivation
similarly an other group headed by
atol humar at the toronto general
hospital have also conducted
studies in kidney transplant patient
have they shown again
that if you are cmv quantiform reactive
you have a very very
low chance of getting any evidence of
cmv disease in these patients
whereas if your cmv non-reactive that is
if you don't have a reconstituted
immunity
as measured by quantifying assay you
have an increased risk of cmb active
reactivation in fact atul has again
extended this work
has now actually shown that you post
prophylaxis
you can actually measure the cmb
quantifying uh
you can measure cm immunity using
quantify technology
and if you are actually positive for cmb
reactivity that is your your t cell
immunity is normal and have you
reconstitute
you actually don't need to these give
any further treatment and it can remain
cmb free if you're non-reactive and if
you don't treat these patients
they have a very high chance of getting
cmv reactivation as shown in the red
line here
having established the immune monitoring
as a diagnostic strategy or predictable
strategy for
identifying patients who are high risk
of
infectious complication particularly
viral infection we have taken one step
forward and tried to bring in
a new form of clinical management where
we use
adoptive t cell therapy for treatment of
cmb ebv or other viral complications in
these transplant patients
in fact and t cell therapy has now
emerged as a powerful tool to to manage
viral infection in transplantation and
number of
clinical centers and biotech industry is
rapidly
coming into this particular area and
trying to develop new strategies
using either autologous or off-the-shelf
t-cell in therapies for treatment of
viral infection transplant here is an
example of a patient
who we treated with cmb specific t cells
this was a stem cell transplant patient
who actually developed a very severe cmv
colitis
following allergenic stem cell
transplant as you can see here
this patient had a very severe bleeding
in his colon
and and you can see these brown dots
which actually indicate cmp replication
going on and this
histology clearly shows severe damage by
the viral infection
and when the patient came to us he was
having multiple diarrheal episodes
and we were able to grow
cmv specific t cells from patients own
blood and when we gave him this t cell
therapy within six months the patient
was completely
cured and showed a complete resolution
of cmb colitis
and the at the architecture of the colon
returned to the normal and there was no
detectable cmv
activation in there in the gut anymore
here is another example of a
pediatric patient who actually developed
um
cmv retinitis which is a infection in
the eye
and we actually were able to get the
immune cells from
from his donor um and in this case the
patient actually had a very high viral
load in the peripheral blood
also in in the retina and there when we
we grew the immune cells the patient
received two cycles of six
t-cell therapies uh and each of the
cycle the patient shows a dramatic
improvement in the viral load
and showed a complete resolution of cmv
retinitis
as shown in the images here we have also
treated young kids with
adenoviral infection with post stem cell
transplant here is an example where
actually we're seeing rapidly
replicating
viral load with the green line and we
gave multiple infusions of adoptive t
cell therapy and showed it come and the
patient showed a complete resolution
of adenoviral infection
we've also used them these t-cell
therapies to treat
solid organ transplantation not just
stem cells in this case the pa
this is a patient who had a lung
transplant um the underlying cystic
fibrosis
and within a few weeks of
post-transplant patients started to
develop
ebv positive lymphomas in the liver and
in this case the patient
we draw the blood and we were able to
grow the immune cells in this case ebv
specific t
cells and patients showed complete
resolution of
these lymphomas by 20 weeks clearly
showing you the
the power of these immune cells
particularly the in vitro manufactured t
cells for the treatment of multiple
viral infections
in particularly we have been very
interested in in
in treating the cmb associated
complications in
solid organ transplant patients previous
studies have shown that
long-term use of prophylaxis as i
mentioned earlier uh often leads to drug
resistance
and and once the patient develops
resistance to drugs like gonzaclovir
they have a very um high chance of
having mortality or height level of
mobility associated with this particular
drug resistance
a few years ago we started a clinical
trial or using the cmb specific t-cell
therapy
in renal transplant heart and lung and
heart transplant patients
and what we do is in this process we
manufacture the cmb t cell from that
we take the peripheral blood from the
transplant recipient
and we mix these with the cmb pep mix
which is actually a combination of
class 1 and class 2 restricted epitopes
and these cells are then cultured for a
short period with il-21
which leads to the expansion of the t
cells and then we add
what we call il-2 growth factor il-2
and this cells then rapidly expand
within two weeks
as a large number of these cells undergo
very stringent testing for microbial
test
contamination and also they go through
cellular and
potency testing as well once the cells
are fully
characterized they can then be
transferred back to the clinic
for infusions and usually we give around
one to two mil
10x7 per meter square
we have a dedicated facility at our
institute which is specifically designed
to manufacture
these cell-based therapies this is one
of the largest cell therapy
manufacturing facility in australia
we have 14 clean rooms and of each of
these covers around 2000 square meter
area
and has been fully licensed by tgaf for
for t cell therapy manufacture for
clinical trials
here is the characterization of cmbt
cell products that we have manufactured
from multiple patients
and on the left hand side corner there
you can see these t
cells when we expand they're
predominantly around 90
cells are t cells of these combination
of cd8 and cd4 t
cells you do see some nk cells in there
and very small proportion probably
almost negligible and b
cells and in the second graph from the
left
you can see there is an and the
frequency of cmb specifics is a dramatic
increase once you expand these t cells
over 14 days
and we notice that the regardless of the
transplant we could expand
t cells from all different type of all
different patients
and also it didn't matter whether the
patient was recipient was cmv negative
or positive before the transplant
we could expand comparable number of t
cells
although there was a trend of better t
cell expansion in cmb positive
recipients uh compared to cme negative
the safety profile of this t-cell
therapy absolutely brilliant you know in
fact
we've hardly seen any um t-cell therapy
associated uh
severe uh adverse event um generally
these are mild to moderate
and your patients might report nausea
malaise or fatigue
or sometimes you know they might have
additional sort of um symptoms
but generally are not necessarily suited
with t-cell therapy
quite safe to give these details in fact
this is a
quite a complicated table um not to sort
of go through each bits of it the simple
stories that we recruited around 13
patients and of those
11 patients showed clinical improvement
and
5 were complete responders that is that
we could completely resolve either their
cmb disease
or the viral load and 6 had a partial
response
and two had no response um
so this actually it was a very clear-cut
indication that
how powerful or how cmvt cell therapy
can be used for the treatment of these
in these
patients here's an example of one of
those patients it was a kidney
transplant patient and you can see this
red line
with the red dots is a viral load the
blue line
is the cmv specific t cells which are
actually making it from gamma
the black line shows the actually poly
functional t cells and clearly as the
patient
is given t cell therapy shown by the
these black arrows
and they actually show the resolution of
the viral infection
the t cell immunity improves and you can
see that as the t cell immunity improves
the viral load goes down the patient
shows a complete response
at the same time we also see the
reconstitution of what we call the cd8
positive cd57 positive cell shown in the
red line
and of course is coincident with the
reconstitution of cmv immunity
and of course we have done a bit more
complicated immunological set of
analysis which we call tcr repertoire
remodeling
and all the patients who show clinical
responses show beautiful reconstitution
of t-cell immunity but also
you get you get to see this by deep
sequencing
remodeling of the t-cell receptors the
whole repertoire changes with time
in these patients so they're clearly
showing long-term establishment of cmv
specific immunity in these
patients
in spite of these successes uh in in
these patients
there are a number of challenges and one
of the major one or few of these
challenges are
the autologous cellular therapy
manufacturing from transparent patient
is often very complicated and we do see
failures particularly specifically in
those patients who are lymphopenic
and who have been on the antiviral drugs
for too long
we actually need to develop rapid access
t cell therapy for critical ill patients
because their time period between the
and the disease onset and the time that
it takes to manufacture these tests
often is quite long
and also we have to identify precise
clinical core is successful cellular
therapy
one of the approach that we have been
collaborating with the tarot bio
therapeutics is to develop this what we
call
off-the-shelf approach what the
off-the-shelf approach is is such a
powerful one then you can actually take
immune cells from healthy donors and
take the peripheral blood mononuclear
cells from the
blood collected from healthy virus
carries like you and i
and then these cells are actually
sensitized with the antigen they're
grown in the bioreactors
and you can grow these multiple doses of
t
cells and store it down in liquid
nitrogen
and what you do is you then match these
t cells with appropriate transplant
recipient
and using a proprietary algorithm and
that cells can be shipped to the patient
within 24 to 48 hours rather than taking
two weeks or
two four weeks we can now provide these
t-cell therapies
off the shelf within 48 hours here is an
example
of a study conducted by atara bio
therapeutics in collaboration with this
memorial salon catering institute uh
here they were showing beautiful you
know
clinical responses up to 60 plus percent
um
overall survival when you're given the
ebv
specific t cells uh which had been grown
as an off-the-shelf t-cell therapy
allergenic there are a few
treatment-related serious elements
very few no infusion-related toxicities
no cytokinry syndrome and only one case
of graf versus host disease showing just
remarkable results both in hematopoietic
stem cell transplantation
and solid organ transplant the
remarkable thing is that
the overall response is pretty similar
around 60
there have been number of studies now
been published around close to 300
patients been treated
and what is more interesting is that you
can see how many crs are there their
complete response
and very few adverse events very rarely
the patients have been showing
any adverse effect of the t cell therapy
so just imagine these are the t
cells which have been expanded from
healthy volunteers
and have no relationship to the patient
and use the third-party t-cells and
they're extremely safe and give a
beautiful clinical response
just to summarize um i think the
long-term
what we're going to move away from a
tolerance to off-the-shelf t-cell
therapies and here are my
acknowledgements
my colleagues at the cuyama berghofer
medical research institute particularly
corey smith leonie begley
aishna panickers virahan gary brooks and
linda jones and many others
who have contributed to this many years
of work
of developing these t-cell therapies for
various infectious complications
and my clinical colleagues at royal
adelaide hospital princess alexander
hospital in brisbane
prince charles hospital and royal
brisbane hospital again in brisbane and
the
staff at the kyogen cell therapeutics
where we actually manufacture our
t-cells
thank you very much thank you professor
khanna
for the great presentation from this
morning we had
five speakers in this theme and we have
learned a lot of different innovative
approaches from them
let's take a small break and join again
for live q and a shortly
thank you
[Music]
this is life
[Music]
a moment of joy
a dream come true all pure love
a tiny breakthrough
or maybe a triumph a constant
struggle a clash of ideas
we can make a difference create the
new the unexpected
[Music]
leading us to feel great strong
or simply human
constantly questioning
are we curious enough
could we be closer
can we
[Music]
can you feel it